un intento de emancipación la primera
ministra se desmarca del presidente
titulares como ese encabezan varios
medios franceses de prensa este viernes
es que en medio del actual crisis social
Elizabeth declaró en una entrevista al
diario lemundo que el momento exige
apaciguar calmar no humillar a los
sindicatos son palabras que parecen un
llamado de atención directa a Emanuel
macron por sus ataques recientes contra
líder del sindicato con mayor cantidad
de adherentes del país pero fue otra
idea la que provocó un correctivo
tajante por parte del el Eliseo La
Premier subrayó que es necesario un
respiro un período de convalecencia si
la reforma de pensiones pasa la prueba
de fuego del Consejo constitucional la
semana que viene admitió que se requiera
aportar respuestas concretas a este
periodo difícil y en pleno vuelo entre
Pekín y cantón los asesores del
presidente se acercaron a la prensa para
poner a la Premier en su sitio
declararon a los periodistas a bordo que
el rumbo lo traza el presidente y las
respuestas que necesita el país también
las dio el mandatario el mes pasado su
indicación Es que la reforma de
pensiones se aplicará antes de fin de
año y punto a esto y como buen soldado
ante las cámaras aclaró hace un par de
horas que ella y el presidente están
completamente alineados también hay Luis
Miguel el nuevo signo de la crisis de la
escasez de combustible que afecta sobre
todo a la región capitalina Cuál es la
situación en estos momentos
aquí en París y los departamentos que
conforman la región de la capital hay
27% de gasolineras afectadas por la
escasez de combustible en algunos hasta
40 por ciento de las estaciones no
tienen gasolina o diésel la situación es
más complicada este fin de semana de
pascua cuando se multiplican los
desplazamientos y recordemos la escasez
se debe a las huelgas contra la reforma
de pensiones que mantienen bloqueadas
algunas refinerías del país y detenida
totalmente la más grande de Francia en
normandía tras fracasar a las
negociaciones con los sindicatos el
gobierno decidió acceder por la fuerza a
las instalaciones y obligar a algunos
operarios a regresar al trabajo pero esa
decisión fue revertida ayer por un
tribunal de Justicia porque atenta
contra el derecho constitucional a la
huelga no obstante la situación debería
mejorar ligeramente la próxima semana
según estimaciones de las empresas que
suministran los carburantes